[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: If you have
a dataset in BigQuery
that you wish to copy within
a region or from one region
to another, you can do so
without needing to extract,
move, and reload the data.
In this video, you
will learn two ways
to copy a BigQuery dataset
using the cloud console.
Both options require
three preparation steps.
First, review the
required permissions
in the documentation
page linked below
to ensure you have the
roles needed for the source
dataset, destination dataset,
and for creating transfers.
Second, you must create
the destination dataset
where you would like
the copy to live.
In this tutorial, we will
create the destination dataset
in the same project.
However, this is not required.
Third, you must enable
the BigQuery Data Transfer
Service in the same project
as the source dataset.
From the Navigation menu, choose
APIs & Services and Dashboard.
Click to enable APIs & Services.
Search for BigQuery
Data Transfer API,
then click Enable.
Navigate back to BigQuery
using the search bar.
Now, we are ready to
see the two options
for copying your dataset.
Option one is using
the Copy Dataset icon.
This method is simple, quick,
and perfect for a one time
dataset copy.
Select the dataset
name of the source
dataset that you want to copy.
Click the Copy Dataset icon.
In the Copy Dataset dialog,
select the project ID
and destination dataset ID.
Optionally, check the Overwrite
Destination Table box,
if you want to
refresh or overwrite
the data and schema
of the tables
in the destination dataset.
Click Copy.
A Permissions window may appear
to give the BigQuery Data
Transfer Service permission
to manage your dataset copy.
If so, click to allow.
You can see the
progress and view
details of the dataset
copy under Transfers.
Back in the BigQuery
console, you
will see the tables populate
under your destination dataset,
once the transfer completes.
Consider deleting
the old dataset
to avoid additional
storage costs,
if that makes sense
for your use case.
Now, let's see option number
two, using the transfers UI.
This option is best
if you want to copy
a dataset on a scheduled basis.
In the left-hand
nav, click Transfers.
Click CREATE TRANSFER.
In the source dropdown,
choose Dataset Copy.
Give the transfer a name.
In the Schedule
Options section, you
can choose when the
transfer will execute.
And also, you may
set the transfer
to repeat at regular intervals.
We will choose to start
the transfer immediately
and schedule it
to execute weekly.
Now, choose your destination
dataset in the dropdown.
You must copy in the name of
your source dataset and project
ID.
Remember to use your project
ID, not your project name.
Check the Overwrite
Destination Table
box, if you want to refresh all
data in the destination data
set.
You can also receive email
notifications if and when
a transfer fails.
Click Save.
You can see progress and
view details of the dataset
in the transfers UI.
Once the transfer
completes, you will
see the tables populate under
your destination data set.
Back in the transfers
UI, make sure you
use the three dots to delete or
disable the recurring transfer,
to avoid ongoing charges.
There you have it--
two different ways
to copy data sets,
depending on your needs.
At general availability,
data copied between regions
is billed at the
same rates as pricing
for compute engine network
egress between regions.
BigQuery sends compressed data
for copying across regions,
so the gigabytes build
may actually be less
than the size of your dataset.
All standard BigQuery
usage charges
for storage and querying will
apply on the copied data.
More information on copying
datasets and pricing
is linked in the
description below.
Happy analyzing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]